j'ai passé ces sept dernières années à
parcourir le monde pour parfaire mon art
voyez-vous je suis une sorte de magicien
inventeur et chocolatier alors taisez
moi et écoutez vous non c'est pas ça je
voulais dire l'inverse
monsieur Wonka je vois que vous êtes un
homme très ingénieur qu'est-ce que tu
fais
oh là bien sûr tu l'aimes comment noir
blanc fondu totalement givré il y a des
gens sont venus ici pour vendre du
chocolat tous ont été broyés par le
cartel des chocolatiers il faut vendre
du chocolat pour avoir une boutique et
il faut avoir une boutique pour vendre
du chocolat
interdit de rêver
un double rang du papier j'ai une idée
je sais que tu n'as pas une vie facile
mais tout va s'arranger
promis juré craché il y a pas plus
solennel comme promesse
alors que celui-ci est tout bonnement
étrange qu'est-ce qui se passe
je voudrais dans le chocolat qui fait
voler nous allons vite le savoir qui
voudrait un choix communs
à part un petit groupe de personnes qui
défilent de la gravité
mesdames et messieurs des galeries
gourmets
je suis monsieur woodygon il est doué
trop doué
je pense que j'ai dû prendre dans les
100 kg en deux semaines
vous pourriez changer sa vie monsieur
manga changez leur vie à tous
toutes les bonnes choses dans ce monde
ont commencé par un rêve
pour ne renonce pas au
tien nous y sommes
mamaneuse chocolaterie que le monde
n'est jamais vu
alors c'est vous le drôle de petit
bonhomme qui me suit partout je vous
signale que je suis d'une taille
parfaitement respectable pour un homme
palumba
laissez-moi vous rafraîchir la mémoire
je ne veux pas entendre ça trop tard
j'ai commencé à danser une fois lancée
je ne peux pas m'arrêter
[Musique]